In the game of thrones, you win, or you die,
and a lot of fans apparently saw their hopes
for a good ending go down in flames with the
series finale.
What did people have to say about the series'
controversial conclusion?
Here are some of the more searing reactions.
Tragic, ironic, and maybe inevitable, Jon
Snow ended his arc not sitting the Iron Throne,
but instead as the slayer of both his kin
and his queen.
Jon's stabbing of Daenerys in the destroyed
throne room of the Red Keep is exactly the
kind of story turn we've come to expect from
Game of Thrones.
But the turns it took to get there felt pretty
rushed to a lot of people.
"So what happened to her?"
"Well—"
"The quick version."
One poster expressed sympathy for Daenerys
as a character, writing,
"a moment of silence for daenerys targaryen,
a victim to horrible writing and a rushed
story.
may she rest in peace"
Others took the conclusion of her story personally,
with more than one poster expressing real
frustration.
According to one commenter,
"daenerys deserves SUCH a better death.
after all she’s done, good and bad, she’s
one of the most iconic characters in television
history...and that death did not do her justice
AT ALL.
I’M MAD."
Even people who liked the finale seemed to
express some frustration with the speed at
which Daenerys' story developed.
"Initial #GameOfThronesFinale thoughts: An
excellent finale.
I still think Dany's decisions were rushed
but the outcome was satisfying and there were
strong character moments for just about everyone,
especially Tyrion."
Some wondered just where Dany's guards were
during her final encounter with Jon, who was
able to easily stab the queen during a private
moment, at a time when the loyalty of her
advisors was actively being questioned.
As one writer put it,
"why did Tyrion have more guards then Daenerys?
Why did they take Jons weapon away when he
saw Tyrion but not Dany?"
One commenter broke it down as follows:
"That was terrible.
Like she'd just wander off to the throne room
alone without some Unsullied or Dothraki guarding
her, especially from the likes of Jon Snow,
whom she said betrayed her and was the biggest
threat to her claim to the throne."
Others outright rejected the idea that Daenerys
would have gone so mad so fast, still feeling
the sting of her sudden heel turn in the previous
episode, "The Bells."
Immediately after the finale, the overall
impression was that even if her turn to villany
could have worked, the story felt just too
sped up.
One of the most surprising outcomes of the
Game of Thrones finale involved the out-of-nowhere
crowning of Bran Stark as king of the seven,
scratch that, six, kingdoms.
Twitter had a field day with the unexpected
turn, and plenty of viewers were gobsmacked
by the idea that it was even happening at
all.
In the words of one critic,
"So Bran gets to be king, despite the fact
that he just put his name on the group project
and didn’t do any work."
Others found humor in the idea that Bran,
with his ability to see the future, has apparently
been waiting patiently for everything to be
put into place so that he might take the throne.
As one commenter said,
"So for like 6 seasons, Bran been in his room
singing 'I Just Can’t Wait to Be King' to
himself."
Some posters got nostalgic for the early days
of the show, and pointed out once again how
consequential Jaime Lannister's actions were
when he first pushed Bran from a Winterfell
window.
In the words of one writer,
"Jamie’s [kingslaying] level is so high
he tried to kill Bran 8 years in advance"
And of course, plenty of people had jokes
to share about Bran's wheelchair taking the
place of the Iron Throne, with one poster
writing,
"Dany broke the wheel and ended up with two
more"
As for Isaac Hempstead Wright himself, all
the actor had to share on Twitter in the wake
of the finale on Twitter was a simple crown
emoji and a shrug of the shoulders.
One other big development of the finale was
the conclusion of Arya Stark's story, with
the tomboy royal family member evolving from
desperate survivor to trained assassin, and
finally to an explorer of the worlds beyond
Westeros.
Was it a satisfying end?
One writer asked,
"So who had “Arya invents colonialism”
in their end of show pool"
Others saw sequel story potential, with one
poster writing,
'I’d watch an Arya Goes West spin-off just
saying."
Others couldn't help but see dramatic similarities
between the ending of Game of Thrones and
the ending of The Lord of the Rings.
As one observer noted,
"Remember when they told us how different
#GameOfThones was from Lord of the Rings and
how it subverted everything ever...Arya goes
into the west.
Sam writes There and Back Again.
Coooooool."
During Game of Thrones final episodes, much
has been made of the idea of character assassination.
Jaime seemingly throwing away years of growth
to go be bad with his sister one last time;
Daenerys throwing away years of stately ambition
and just going full rampage mode on King's
Landing.
It's impossible to deny that plenty has happened
to cause many fans, and even the series' actors,
to wonder what their characters are thinking.
"...they've put the women and children in
a crypt with all the dead people, so… blah.
Tyrion is smart, but I guess not that smart."
But no instance of out-of-character behavior
so incensed viewers as Jon Snow's cold farewell
to his loyal direwolf, Ghost, in episode four.
Fans were outraged that Jon, who had the idea
for the Stark children to adopt the direwolves
in the first place, would so callously send
his dog away after years of sacrifice and
fighting along his side.
The poor boy lost an ear for the one-time
King in the North, and he didn't even pet
him goodbye.
What a royal jerk!
"To the traitor and bastard Jon Snow."
But all of this was forgiven when the finale
had know-nothing Jon Snow finally smile, kneel
down, and just give a good pet to his loyal
dog.
Responding to the backlash, series director
David Nutter initially said the two hadn't
interacted during their goodbye thanks to
the difficulty of rendering the CGI direwolf,
an excuse which many took as being kind of
a stretch.
When Jon ultimately did embrace the wolf during
the finale, one poster reacted with relief,
writing,
"Game of Thrones somehow found the money to
allow Jon Snow to pet his dog Ghost."
Another writer cheekily proposed the idea
that the scene reeked of a quick fix, saying,
"they totally shot that Ghost scene on like
Wednesday afternoon, didn't they"
Others made it seem as though this one moment
single-handedly redeemed the series, despite
any perceived late-game flaws.
According to one commenter,
"Good boy Ghost finally got the love he deserved.
My happy ending for #GameOfThrones."
Plenty of other commenters just used the occasion
to post their favorite animated .gifs of dogs
and direwolves.
The Game of Thrones finale may be contentious,
but beloved pets deserving affection is one
thing it seems every viewer can agree on.
As Game of Thrones came to a close, some were
incensed not only at the final episode, but
all the events that led up to it during the
final season as a whole.
To these critics, the finale was a capstone
on many episodes' worth of questionable writing
and bad creative decisions.
Speaking generally, YouTuber Jacksepticeye
wrote,
"Game of Thrones feels like the showrunners
knew where they wanted the characters to end
up but had no idea how to get them there this
season.
It felt incredibly rushed and ham fisted.
What a waste of amazing lore and world building."
Another writer criticized the plot developments
in general with a searing summary, tweeting,
"so we waited 2 years for
- the night king to be stabbed in his crop
top and die easier than the mountain
- cersei to get trampled by rocks
- jon to stab daenerys only for BRAN to become
king
- [and] jon to [fly] back to nights watch
when there r no white walkers??"
Summing up her own disappointment, author
Madeleine Roux said,
"I'd just like to point out that the last
spoken words of Game of Thrones were: I once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel."
She followed it up with a subsequent tweet,
saying,
"I can't BELIEVE I have to clarify this but:
This is not a good thing."
In the hours since the series ended, these
takes have been accompanied by many, many
others, commenting on a finale that seems
destined to be a point of contention for years
to come.
But whether people are outraged, resigned,
or genuinely okay with how the series wrapped
up, the story is finally over, and now our
watch has ended.
Best of luck with that prequel series, HBO.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
fantasy series are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.